hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I decided to pick up little nightmares
over the weekend I needed a break from
my other horror titles but I wanted
something that was eerie and still had
elements of horror
I enjoyed these few hours witless
madness so much that I wanted to tell
you eight reason why little nightmares
deserves a spot in your game collection
to get you in the right mindset I'm
going to start off by comparing little
nightmares with other games that you may
have played in the past if you've ever
played the two masterpieces limbo or
inside then you know what to expect here
not only those little nightmares use a
very similar control system and puzzle
platformer elements it also has a very
similar take on ambiguous narrative and
storytelling and showing things in a
visual way wherever possible
let's look at the aesthetic in the
setting first little nightmares please
view in the shoes or lack of shoes of
six a tiny yellow raincoat wearing child
give a no backstory or understanding of
where she is or what she should do next
you have a tiny lighter to illuminate
the nooks and crannies you tentatively
wonder through but it isn't quite enough
to fully assess your next step
keeping you on edge in where's your
scare horror just can't compete with the
environment you pass through is
deliberately oversized adding to the
wonderment of being a child in
unfamiliar surroundings it isn't a
well-kept world its rundown its
rat-infested and you're witness of
shocking sight taking center stage you
will see a pair of legs above a chair
with a letter close by but you are not
given any more information you are
forced to paint your own picture as he
committed suicide did he leave a note I
even tried to pick up the letter as I
was so engrossed in the deliberate lack
of explanation at any in every step of
this game the story is deliberately
vague throughout and you'll be
scratching your head about what the
narrative could be even after finishing
the game you'll be unsure what just
happened
the desire to escape the hostile
environment is the fixation the game
implanting you early on and the more the
ocean facility you awaken has many
levels to progress through with
different distinct visuals
in the early parts of the game you are
seemingly in the prison and a kitchen
six is regularly overpowered by hunger
pins and you are forced to try out new
cuisine in order to continue your
journey in terms of mechanical nightmare
is a slick platformer with small puddles
thrown in regularly although it's
effectively a side scroll the
verticality of each environment is
breathtaking
I find myself checking how deep the
chasm was by pushing objects into the
void and waiting for the impact on the
ground below duty our diminutive stature
pressing buttons can be difficult and
requires thought even listening a small
key can cause issues for 6 which leads
me into the real mechanic of this game
hide-and-seek
[Music]
I know it sounds childish and that's
exactly how we should feel hiding under
a table in the hooks your enemy will
walk past is enough to make you hold
your breath running too fast will also
alert enemies meaning creeping slowly is
sometimes with a greater option but
feels like a lifetime of torment for
your heart the enemies you encounter are
a marvel of artistry and unique action
from the leeches that can smother you in
a split second to the janitor who can
reach you from seemingly miles away the
nuances each encounter offer are
spectacular the boss fights that follow
although brief are enough to keep you
thinking about the game days later in a
world where games are expected to last
20 plus hours and offer robust online
support little nightmares dares to be
different this is a single story with no
additional roots to uncover or hidden
items to unlock it does approach
collectables with little norm characters
locate and dole figurines to smash in
order to unlock concept art for the
campaign well it lasted me about three
hours I have spoken to other people
who've taken up to eight hours to
progress through the story and others
suggest about five hours is the typical
length to get through this game at this
point I can't decide if the short length
is a positive or a criticism but one
thing is for certain I want to play more
and not many games make me feel that way
the game's length is reflected in the
price of the product here in the UK it
retails around 16 pounds and in the US
it's only $20 so around a third of the
price of a typical video game only you
can decide if you think it's worth it I
wanted to finish off by assuring you
that this is completely my own opinion
I bought little nightmares from my own
wallet I wasn't asked to review it I
wasn't paid to do this PlayStation
granade is independent and we are very
proud to be so have you tried little
nightmares and what do you think to it
oh what the heck is the story about
please post your opinions below but put
a spoiler tag on anything to do with the
story
I am Adam from PlayStation granade I've
seen
time